pop
non ce n'est pas la vraie guerre on est
tenté de dire ce n'est pas encore la
deuxième guerre du coq dans ce pays qui
vit sur les armes depuis 23 ans
chacun se souvient de la guerre qui
entre 1950 et 1953 avait fait 2 millions
de tués leurs mystique bien sûr n'a
réglé aucun des problèmes alors dû deux
côtés on s'entraîne sans cesse on montre
sa force à l'adversaire tout près de la
zone démilitarisée ans procède à des
exercices comme le montrent ces images
au sud d'une armée de 600 mille hommes
appuyés par 40 2000 amérique une arme
est d'ailleurs très américanisée et même
en quelque sorte prisonnière de la force
aérienne des états unis au nord quatre
cent mille hommes mais deux millions le
gars de rouge
arm est disponible sur leur pour le
combat des fortifications partout de
part et d'autre des centaines de chars
du dernier modèle et les avions les plus
modernes deux pays frères qui se sont
transformés en deux forteresses prêtes à
s'affronter
le terrain un terrain idéal pour jouer à
la guerre et de l'avis des experts en
cas de conflit seoul serait indécent
dame
encore bon
bon
sur la ligne du cessez le feu à
panmunjom sur le 38e parallèle
là où fut signé l'armistice
[Musique]
nord-coréens et sud-coréens avec leurs
alliés américains à côté et finnois de
l'autre se rencontrent régulièrement
depuis 23 ans un dialogue de sourds on
ne se parle pas on ne se regarde même
pas on se parle seulement de temps en
temps des papiers toujours des
accusations chacun fait son petit exposé
retransmis par haut parleur mais ceux
d'en face simule la plus parfaite
indifférence
ah ah
pourtant depuis 23 ans le cessez-le-feu
a été violé environ vingt-cinq mille
fois les nord-coréens ont infiltré 3910
saboteurs et commandos et d'ailleurs ils
ont bien failli assassiner le président
de corée du sud
l'année dernière les sud coréens ont
découvert les tunnels fabriqués par les
nord coréens
chacun de ces tunnel qui passe sous la
zone démilitarisée pouvait permettre le
passage de cinq divisions en trois jours
pour envahir la corée du sud alors la
corée du sud est devenue l'un des pays
les mieux armés de l'extrême-orient
une armée de tif américaine un matériel
américain mais aussi de la part des sud
coréens une volonté de plus en plus
grande de se démarquer les états unis
pour pouvoir assurer eux-mêmes des sols
[Musique]